[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL SAXMAN: Hello and welcome
to a special pre-I/O episode
of Google Maps Developers
live.
This week Brendan, Mano, and I
have been joined by a team,
Instrument, who's working on a
map dive exhibit for Google
I/O. They're going to give
us a demo and introduce
themselves.
And then we'll talk a little
bit about the technology.
So with that, Instrument team,
do you guys mind letting us
know what you're working
and who you are?
MARTIN LINDE: I'm
Martin Linde.
I'm the creative director on
the project at some of the
labs groups here
at Instrument.
BEN PURDY: And I'm Ben Purdy,
and I am a technical lead and
have been doing a bunch of the
development on this thing.
MARTIN LINDE: So just a little
background about Instrument.
We're a small, or medium
sized creative agency
in Portland, Oregon.
And we actually started out as
basically purely a dev shop
with just a little bit
of design farmed out.
And it's grown to about 80
people now doing everything
from website development to
motion graphic and content
production.
And it's a cool opportunity to
be working on this project,
particularly since that's what
the labs group within
Instrument was formed as.
So we'd love to show you the
demo of the Map Diving.
So Ben will go outside,
and I will try to
narrate what he's doing.
So what you're seeing right now
on the seven big screens
here are the attract mode.
And Ben will raise his arms to
sort of attract Pegman to fly
towards him.
And now he will raise his arms
so that the Kinect or the Asus
device will recognize him.
It will do like a pirouette and
then fly over a countdown
above the clouds.
And that's just to orient the
user as to what's going on.
And let them get a
feel for flying.
And now the level starts.
So he's diving down towards
a zoomable Google Map.
And the objective of
the game is to hit
gates and bonus stars.
And the way that it works
is if you have your arms
stretched out, you're planing
out and can sort of move
vertically in the air--
or horizontally, sorry.
And then when you move your
arms closer to your
body, you will dive.
And so that's what he's
doing right here.
And he does a little loop once
he hits a gate and a barrel
roll when he hits a star.
And every so often, the map will
reload to get you closer
to the ground, so to speak.
And it's super responsive and
fun to watch, even, and even
more fun to play.
So we'll let just Ben
show his skill.
And he purposefully missed
an object in space there.
People at I/O will be able
to see the bonus
rounds there will be.
There's 13 base maps that takes
on a normal Google Map.
And then there's about five
bonus modes that are just fun
takes, and more intense levels
that will give you bonus
multipliers and more points.
So we look forward to
showcasing those.
And so you see in the
distance there sort
of a pulsing graphic.
And that's kind of
the drop zone.
And so you're diving over 13
locations in the world.
And right now we're over Statue
of Liberty in New York.
And so he has just managed to
hit the drop zone, and we'll
initiate the celebration
sequence right here.
And so that's kind of a
cinematic cut sequence.
And he will circle the Statue of
Liberty, and after a couple
of seconds, he basically
will take off up
into the sky again.
And that's the basic gameplay.
You can miss, and then a
parachute will deploy.
So to show you that you
weren't quite as good.
And then quickly you can get
back to it and try again.
And so, without further ado,
here is Ben describing the
magic behind this thing.
BEN PURDY: All right.
So as you can see, this is a
multi-screen experience.
I'll just go through, really
quickly, what is driving the
actual display and game.
So each one of these seven
monitors is being run off of a
separate PC.
And every single one of those is
just an instance of Chrome
running in full screen.
This whole thing is built
on JavaScript and web
technologies.
All of the communication is
handled through WebSockets
just routing messages through
an instance of Node.js.
So there's no native custom apps
running except for the
body tracking, which is an
openFrameworks app using
OpenNI and a 3D camera,
sort of like a Kinect.
So that's what's driving
this thing.
Each of the view ports is
basically just showing the
current game state.
And then we have another PC that
is not connected to any
of the game displays.
There's a podium that you can
see in the scene there that is
running the game logic.
And then game state is sent
out to all seven of the
displays at about 60 hertz,
which is what we try to keep
the frame rate at.
So it's pretty ambitious
for something running
completely in Chrome.
But it's been a breeze
to work with.
And the synchronization between
the displays has been
not much of a problem at all.
So that's basically
what's driving it.
We use the three.js WebGL
library to do all of the 3D
objects in the foreground.
And the map plane is
actually an HTML
Google Map that's live.
There's no trickery going on.
It's just being transformed
using 3D CSS to stay in sync
with the WebGL camera.
So what you're seeing is an
actual live Google Map.
If I hadn't turned off the user
input, you could actually
drag and zoom and pan
on the thing.
Even though that would distort
the game experience, it really
is there, really is running.
MARTIN LINDE: [INAUDIBLE].
BEN PURDY: Yeah.
So that's been a fun experience
trying to marry the
3D CSS with WebGL.
Additionally, we had to do some
interesting trickery to
get the view synchronized.
So what we ended up doing is
having a dummy object in 3D
space that we attached the
actual camera to, and then we
just offset the rotation of that
camera depending on the
view index.
And then as long as each
viewport is rendering the same
scene, and since they're all
synchronized over the network,
the scene stays in sync.
Then once you put the view
side by side, everything
stitches together.
So what I was also going to talk
about a little bit was
the tools that we had to make
to build this thing.
And what we ended up doing is
building the tool to create
levels using, again it
just runs in Chrome.
And then we used Google
Maps extensively
to create this tool.
The whole game space is actually
tied to real world
coordinates.
And so we just have a
translation between actual
latitude and longitude
and our game space.
And so that makes it really easy
to design these courses
which are laid out at various
points over the globe.
So we actually have a Google
Map where we can just drop
items and kind of practice
courses and
that sort of thing.
And so I can walk through the
editor here a little bit.
You're going to have to forgive
my sort of UX-less
developer console
styling here.
And another caveat I must say
is that I designed this to
work on the touch
screen podium.
And so these big fat buttons
are as a result
of my big fat fingers.
So I'll just run through
this really quick.
Again, this is the behind the
scenes, nobody should have to
see this poor UI.
But what I have here is both
the admin console that runs
the game, and then the editor
actually runs on top of this.
So you can switch into edit mode
at any time, and it sort
of takes over the game play.
So I've got an instance of the
game running on my local
machine here.
So you can see that my little
Pegman is not falling because
I'm in edit mode right now.
And so that lets me fly around
magically so that I can
position items and see
the layout better.
And so in this admin console,
I've got a map on the left,
which is the overview
of the game space.
And I've got markers
for the player.
And I've got markers for gates
and items you can pick up and
landmarks and that
sort of thing.
There's a lot of pieces that
I've added to make building
levels easier.
So I can center on items.
You can select items from this
list that are all of the
entities in the world.
Double-clicking on
one of those will
center it in the view.
All of these items
are interactive.
One kind of cool thing.
At first, I was building all
the levels just using
this top down view.
And that turned out to be really
cumbersome because it's
really easy to make a level
that's unbeatable if you're
just doing it from
a top down view.
And so eventually I merged the
editor, like I said, into the
actual game engine.
And so with this new system
I'm actually able to--
try to get this on
the screen here.
All of the changes that I'm
making are actually sent live
to the viewports.
So I'm not sure how well the
frame rate will translate to
this screen share, but you can
see that as I'm dragging one
of the objects in the map view,
the 3D object in the
game space is also picking
up those changes.
And the same thing goes for
creating new entities and that
sort of thing.
So it's been really great to not
have to code all of this
map drag and drop.
I use things like checking
to see if a
location is within bounds.
I have some other niceties
to make sure I don't make
unbeatable levels.
If I drag the start point for
the map around, I get this
nice ring that shows me how
far the player needs to be
from the drop zone to be
able to hit it in time.
So I don't end up starting
the player too
far away or too close.
And then I'm even using
geocoding, so that when we're
designing a level, I can just
type in the name of the
location, and it'll prepopulate
some search
results text that we end up
putting on the screen.
So it's been really great, like
I said, to not have to
reinvent all of these
tools to build an
application like this.
We've been able to just focus
on things like the game play
and the graphics.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
So you can actually run all
this on your laptop then?
I mean you can actually play
the game and everything?
BEN PURDY: Yeah, oh yeah.
I mean before we had the seven
displays that we had the game
up and running.
I can set the viewport
dynamically through a little
config file.
So I would just literally open
seven little, tiny, tall,
skinny instances of Chrome and
line them up across the top of
my larger desk monitor.
And then I could simulate what
it would be like when the
monitors showed up.
And then when they showed up, we
just got Chrome running on
them and fired it up.
And it was basically painless
to get this thing working on
the actual distributed
installation versus just on a
single computer.
PAUL SAXMAN: So it sounds like
it's pretty much built all on
open technologies.
BEN PURDY: Like I said,
we're using--
so it's all running in Chrome.
All of the game logic is
JavaScript running in Chrome.
And then Node.js is running
the communications.
And it literally is just a hub
so that the game logic can
broadcast the game messages
out to the
seven display clients.
And then the node also handles
routing the control
information from the body
tracking software.
Which is just a UDP connection
to the Node.js, which then
sends the body tracking.
It's just basically the
angle of your torso
compared to the ground.
And then each arm compared
to the torso.
So we just get three angles
that are being sent to the
control node at as fast
of a frame rate as
the thing can capture.
And so then the control
node integrates that.
I've got a way of normalizing
input so I can play off of the
keyboard or the body tracking.
Or I even have a way to simulate
body tracking using
the mouse cursor.
But that's built on
openFrameworks using OpenNI to
do the body tracking.
Which was pretty fun to
do some debugging and
playing with that.
We had a lot of fun trying to
work out some of the kinks of
having multiple people
in the scene at once.
We did a lot of running around
in circles with lots of people
in the view.
MARTIN LINDE: We should
show that.
BEN PURDY: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
BEN PURDY: Play that back at
like five times speed with a
funny soundtrack.
MANO: The most important
question right now is really
who's the best player
right now?
BEN PURDY: Oh gosh.
I would not want to take on
our technical director.
He's pretty competitive.
And every time I would come
around the corner to try to
test out some change, I would
have to kick him off because
he'd be there trying
to get it perfect.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, I heard when
we were chatting with you
guys earlier, there's some
talk about having a
leaderboard?
That would be--
BEN PURDY: Yeah.
We're working on adding
some capabilities to
do competitive play.
Just in terms of ability of
levels and being able to
one-up your buddies.
PAUL SAXMAN: If not for I/O,
then maybe for the open source
release that we're going
to potentially do.
BRENDAN KENNY: So you guys--
so this is obviously going to
be at I/O. And you guys are
going to be at I/O so that you
can talk to people about this.
So I'm sure a number of
developers are going to be
very interested in
the tech stack.
But then afterwards, can you
talk a little bit about your
plans for this, afterwards?
BEN PURDY: Well, the plan right
now is that we would
like to release the code.
It's going to need
a little bit of
cleanup before that happens.
The code base right now is very
much tuned to some of the
challenges of working on
a distributed display.
It does work on a
single machine.
And I don't foresee a lot of
integration and refactoring
effort required to get this all
working within a single
instance of Chrome.
All I need to do is pull out the
code that would be talking
to Node.js and just basically
have like a
dummy message router.
There's nothing that would
stop it from being like a
single player in a
single browser
experience at this point.
BRENDAN KENNY: Oh great.
MARTIN LINDE: We're also hoping
that some of the tools
that we use for designing levels
that Ben created, also
like a tool that our other
developer, [INAUDIBLE], wrote
to allow us to design tricks for
little Pegman, like barrel
rolls and flips and
glides and things.
They'll be the last things we
add, but we would like to show
that too in open
source as well.
BEN PURDY: There have been a
lot of fun little tools and
tricks along the way.
We actually have full body
motion capture that was
driving an articulated
Pegman at one point.
We've got a lot of pretty neat
little things that we've had
to overcome and play
with for this.
BRENDAN KENNY: So you're doing
from like the openFrameworks
to actual like motion capture
and mapping to Pegman?
BEN PURDY: Yeah, because we
can get all of the actual
joint positions.
And so for the game play, we're
just tracking your arms
and that sort of thing.
But to create assets, rather
than hand animating, we were
going to do like full
body motion capture
of like little Pegmans.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's awesome.
Cool.
We don't want to give too much
away because we'll probably
have some follow-up shows.
Maybe after Google I/O we can do
a technical deep dive with
you guys to talk
a little more.
Maybe look at--
BRENDAN KENNY: Specific APIs
MANO: Once it is released.
PAUL SAXMAN: So for those of you
tuning in, if you're going
to be at I/O, we definitely hope
that you'll have a chance
to kind of play the Map Dive.
And if not, if you're going to
be joining us actually via GDL
or I/O Extended, we're
definitely going to have some
more shows.
And so hopefully you can
join us in spirit.
So thanks for joining
us, Instrument team.
This was really awesome.
MANO: See you guys
in San Francisco.
BEN PURDY: Sounds good.
PAUL SAXMAN: And viewers,
thanks for joining us.
And hope to see you soon.
Buh-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]